time is the enemy Terry for all of us
we're all as time goes on we start to
age or there and you're an amazing shape
as your body sending you any signals now
that maybe you're you're getting a
little older yeah you know what it's
kind of weird I'm 49 I'll be 49 this
year right and I'm you know I'm now
going into energy saving mode you know
like the phone it's like it's kind of
like you know with my libido
it's not where it used to be I mean
there's so many times now where you know
my wife gives me a choice it's like an
app or the other thing and I'm like man
could we just cuddle please
right could we just cuddle and I'm just
as satisfied you know it's where I reach
the stage where I actually dream about
taking a nap yeah that's kind of I'm in
the matrix when you get older and you
start to age out a little bit the same
thoughts that you had about sex when you
were 16 you now have about a nap okay
boy all right let's do this
and it's funny because when we do it's
awesome it's amazing but it's just you
know there are times when I really I'm
like do you want me for me or do you
just want me for this you know I need to
cuddle I need to cuddle and know I'm
right right there's no that's not a
problem in my house I'm quite clear when
I go to my wife do you want is you just
want me for this not a question no
you